welcome to music team with Billy payer
and benefit today's headlines team
bridge revenue team collects council tax
for around fifty five thousand
properties and contrary to popular
belief the money doesn't just go towards
bin collection but also every day
services such as libraries education and
help for the elderly also a portion goes
towards the police and fire services
many discounts are available such as
twenty five percent off if you live
alone and a reduction if you have a
disability and have an adapted property
Billy if you have lost your job or are
on a low income the benefits team could
assist you with paid help with paying
your rent or your cancer tax payments t
brush currently helps over 11,000
households contact us to see if you're
entitled or if you need help completing
your application for just come into fort
house remember team which works hard to
make sure that you get what you're
entitled to remember to give accurate
information about your circumstances to
prevent you being investigated by our
fraud team around 500 cases have been
investigated so far this year now over
to Jenny waves sunny day for small
businesses all across a team which area
is over ninety four percent of small
businesses contacted by the council
received small business rate relief
which can greatly reduce the charge wall
rake relief is available in many areas
such as here here and here which can
also lower your bill a sprinkling of
other businesses such as non profit
making of organizations can also receive
help ok that means our God thank you
very thank you for watching good night